having founded Quilliam my nonprofit
counter extremism organization I'm aware
of the generosity of wealthy donors but
even I was surprised to learn that only
one in ten of the UK's richest people
that's those worth 10 million pounds or
more give anything to charity at all and
despite their total wealth growing by
113 billion pounds in a year
those donating more than 1 percent of
their wealth has plummeted by a quarter
in just two years
deserving recognition as the UK's most
generous giver is Jonathan ruff oh hey
hey who donated three hundred and twenty
million pounds leaving him with 151
million pounds now that's more than
enough to live on and then some London
has more billionaires than any city in
the world but some are now leaving due
to fear of far left tax hikes that may
never be introduced this is all a
terrible indictment the wealthy have a
moral duty to give back rising
inequality leaves the status quo
unsustainable charitable giving can be
one solution but if these patterns
continue the far-left backlash their
wealthy fear and that I do not encourage
may well become a self-fulfilling
prophecy I mean you have I think you've
to go back in history to explain why I'm
about to declare a sell and a vested
interest come into your one intent
somehow that was giving was not the same
in this country it was in America and it
is in America I remember being at the
Harvard Business School where someone
gave me a hole 46 million pound sports
of million dollars bought said in one
year things like that that's because I
think in this country we come from a
tradition of believing the state should
provide and I think we've been very slow
to move away from that when the state
wasn't providing for richer people to
give more money and you remember the
pressure that came on certain rich
people in America when it was seen that
they were not contributing significant
sums to charity
gates gates who has given a fortune
actually didn't for some time for some
years it was under pressure because of
it I happened I don't believe this idea
that you've you made money it's up to
you what you do with it I think there is
an obligation on rich people to pay to
get more not legal right got you can't
make it legal do you well you could you
call it taxation I agree there is a
moral obligation on the rich but you're
wrong Greg to say we should move away
from the model where we expect the state
to take care so we should I said we are
well we need so that's what we need
folks will you no matter the problem for
what you'll say I mean I think it's
great when rich people give to charity
and even you know I'm not by no means
into the top by the way
there are 18,000 people in the UK who
are worth more than 10 million pounds
which I didn't know I'm pretty far from
that but I give money to charity and I
tried to help charities and I think we
all should I'm very uncomfortable with
saying we it should be compulsory
because that is shifting the emphasis
away from what people with money should
do which is pay their taxes we should
pay taxes and make sure we have
well-funded public services and the
problem with the emphasis on charity is
that it's kind of a regressive step in a
way where you go back to people choosing
what causes they think deserves to be
supported you get back to these ideas
about the deserving poor people support
things they find attractive they're
never going to support things that they
find unattractive and that is why we
need public services to make sure that
we have safety nets for everybody who
needs it in society I remember the very
Republican idea who think about you know
in America the reason they get more
charity they pay less have idea that you
should choose who you want to help Erin
you had ten million pounds right if you
had to say you all in that bracket of
the eighteen thousand yeah ten million I
mean would you give to charity of course
I would but but but I'm like after I
don't believe anyone should have a moral
obligation kid if you have two working
kidneys do you have a moral obligation
to give one to someone who else and if
you have a spare room in your house you
have a moral obligation to give it to me
and and you mentioned you mentioned fill
gates before
ok so Bill Gates was vilified as a rich
businessman before he started to give to
charity his wealth made him vilified him
the owner suddenly became a good bloke
and only Beaucaire when he started to
give money away but I think rich people
well ya know rich people give give give
you know they create jobs so it's a
higher form of philanthropy if you're
like Bill Gates has done more with the
businesses he's created for people then
he will ever do with his childhood
because we experience that his his
business every single day of our land be
able to Nick we gotta be able to agree
surely that charitable giving is a good
deed right I mean it sounding like to
answer one or the other I was struck by
a report that Sky News did after the
Sunday Times published its rich list
where the boss of coot switches to
reminder video that's the queen's bank
and supposedly i think you meant have a
million liquid before you can get in or
whatever whatever says clients were more
concerned about jeremy corbyn than
brexit so i'm going to go round the
table which concerns you more jeremy
corbyn in power or bricks you just say
one of the two yes that breakfast lee
[Music]
and also in the same case talked about
the number of people who are taking
money out and they're in surely lies the
problem because of course you're right
if you've got okay and what is happening
rightly or wrongly and that's probably
another conversation is that people who
have done very well who are wealth
creators who do pay a lot in tax and in
some in your sister i know you pay more
than you need to will you pay more to
check these people are being chased out
of the country and that's the thing that
worries me very quickly in Carano you
want to get did you know we are the
second most unequal country in the world
you
but the church's Aid Foundation said
that 48% of people in this country
believes the charities aren't
trustworthy which is maybe why everyone
is giving but the bottom line is isn't
sure if wealthy people have worked very
hard for their money they should be
entitled to do whatever they want to do
with it yes one would hope there is
obligation on people who have made money
to support give back countable
foundations in which people are gonna
flee yeah I've heard that argument all
my life when tax rates were 7080 percent
which people are gonna freak it's funny
they all still hear the definition of a
donation it's supposed to be about
goodwill it's supposed to be done
willingly moral obligation means as
opposed to legal duty I think we're
missing two debates if tax is a legal
duty and giving to charities and moral
the huge ironies about tax is that the
more money you have the more access you
have to not paying it so I used a lawyer
I know lots of lawyers who spend an
automatic I'm creating extremely
complicated structures for their clients
to legally massively minimize their tax
liability through trust that they create
offshore accounts all kinds of vehicles
now the average person cannot they pay a
higher proportion of their income as tax
than the wealthy do now that to me is a
moral problem if you are rich you have a
moral responsibility to pay your fair
share of tax I'm not interested in you
give to charity give to charity it's
great but don't give to charity do both
no but there is a whole industry out
there there's a whole industry in
accountancy and legal world that only
looks at any new legislation and says
what can we do that comes out of the
Treasury what can we do to avoid this
the same people who are doing that are
giving to charities this is my issue now
I'm not saying that they're mutually
something but I think it's more urgent
one in 10 only one in ten welcome to the
fact that Weaver so hey look if you add
I mean is this mr. rougher right I've
just got to recognize him again because
he did give away three hundred
twenty-one million but still has 151
million left nervous
clearly more than enough to live on if
you had 200 million pounds yeah how much
of that do you need to live on I mean
because everyone works hard for their
money right the cookie you know the
person cleaning the streets yeah I work
hard for the money as well but 200
million pounds spare in your pocket it's
never which people it's invested it's
not just even there are some people who
are asset leech but haven't got any
gifts people a lot of people sitting in
London on quite big houses last weekend
saw the culmination of the Premier
League title race a tense battle which
went right for the last weekend when it
came down to it man City pit Liverpool
to the post claiming victory for the
second year in a row but while for some
of the red supporters being so close yet
so far was just too much to bear
one man remained decidedly upbeat after
the final whistle had blown skies Tom
Parmenter caught up with a strangely
familiar face for chat outside an field
let's have a quick chat with one shop we
found outside on field here sir
what do you make of today I mean it was
all on Manchester City you needed them
to failed in you yeah I'm a little bit
set today because there was it was close
only one point it was not our best game
was okay but we're looking forward in
three weeks there's a chamber League
final against sir the Spurs in it I have
a good feeling that we will win that
game because the Spurs are they were
very good in the pitch they're very good
at the Box bar we are better is it just
me or is there something slightly off
about Liverpool manager well mister not
clop you are a faker of the week but
don't forget if you want to join the
debate just search for the pledge on
Facebook or Twitter and you can also
listen to the pledge as a podcast that's
available to download from iTunes now
thanks for watching see you next time